US President Donald Trump has signed a
law backing anti-government
demonstrators in Hong Kong while the
legislation mandates an annual review of
that favorable trade status that
Washington grants Hong Kong it also
threatens sanctions against Chinese
officials who commit human rights abuses
in the territory
China's denounced the bill calling it a
serious interference in its domestic
affairs but it has been welcomed as a
victory by Hong Kong's pro-democracy
movement en-us no matter administration
and a congress they sent a clear signal
to President Xi Hong Kong even it's
under the hotline route of Beijing but
we are also the global city that will
have foreign businessmen or also expat
live here and how to safeguard Hong
Kong's political and economic freedom
that also would be the criteria and also
one of the issue that President Xi or
Koreans should not ignore well joining
us for more on these developments from
Hong Kong now is DW reporter sherry chan
good to see you sherry the activists are
obviously pleased but tell us more about
Beijing's response well right after
Trump signed the legislation Beijing
rieta furiously as expected
it has summoned and the US ambassador to
demand the u.s. not to interfere in
China's internal affairs and it also
asked the u.s. to stop causing further
damage to bilateral relations and also
actually in a statement the foreign
ministry also said that the legislation
has sinister intentions and it's also an
act of bullying it's also accused the
u.s. of being a culprit of instability
in Hong Kong Beijing also want that they
would take a firm countermeasures but
although they didn't mention what
countermeasures would be and it also
said that the US will bear consequences
if it insists to pass the law all right
so what about then on the ground itself
has the University for example now been
cleared of those protesters
it is very hard to estimate
actually how many people are still
inside the campus actually in the past
few days there were several different
groups trying to enter the university to
to look for the protesters one group
organized by newly elected district
councillors they went inside and they
said they met two protesters inside and
another group organized by the school
administration they said they met one
woman but actually right after the
police announced that they would conduct
this search in the morning one protestor
inside the campus met the press and he
said that they were around 20 people
still inside and he also asked the
police to retreat immediately because he
said that everyone who chose to stay
inside they had completely lost trust on
the police and he said that if the
police would retreat and they would
leave the campus on their own all right
but on that point I mean the police say
that this is a clean up operation but is
there the possibility that they may
arrest protesters who they find there on
the campus well and before the police
enter the campus this morning days they
emphasize that this operation would just
focus on removing and explosive and
dangerous items to make sure that the
environment in the campus is safe and
they also said that if they encountered
any individuals in the campus who and
need medical treatment and they said
that they will not make immediate arrest
but they would only record their
personal details but and they didn't
mention what they would do with these
individuals who have their personal
details recorded all right Dee Wu's
Cheri Chan monitoring those developments
in Hong Kong for us as police entered
the campus there in Hong Kong after an
11 day siege thanks very much indeed